[Music]
welcome to Udacity talks number 11 have
this incredible pleasure do you have I
guess the founding father of cloud
computing he ancillary Kaveri with me in
legend and a pioneer in data science
over many many decades I'm rod Avila
from Egypt thank you Rama is CTO of
cloud era one of the earliest partners
of Udacity also founder of cloud era has
a history of selling data science
companies to places like Yahoo which
used to be a company I guess and it's
slowly disintegrating at this point not
a sale
yeah but also born and raised in Egypt I
take it that's correct so when he come
over I came in 1995 yeah yeah yeah of
course you can ask I I was 25 years old
I'm 46 right now so I was 25 back then
and I came with a goal to get my PhD
from Stanford University and then go
back to Egypt and teach I'd love to
teach your father's professor yes my
father is a teacher professor he teaches
economics at Carey University and we
need you in Cairo Cairo University yes
yeah so he's in the Faculty of Commerce
essentially and then you kind of got
stuck yeah you got to be to your ticket
I did finish my PhD I mean there's a
long story around that is I actually
dropped out of my PhD first I created my
first company my first startup which we
have acquired a year later it was a very
small company five people we were
acquired a small acquisition so that we
hired kind of acquisition and then while
at Yahoo I got the itch to finish my PhD
partially because I really wanted to
accomplish that goal but more
importantly because my dad was nagging
me to go back and finish the piece so
yeah so a few years into my stint at
Yahoo I told him I want to go back and
leave Yahoo and they said no you're not
gonna leave us they were very nice to me
they gave me the time to work on my PhD
they also helped my tuition
it's very nice so I was able to go back
and finish the PhD while I was working
at Yahoo yeah interesting and then your
plan was to become professor yourself
yeah that was always my goal
I was a very young kid is a syllable not
anymore
no a frequently joke and say I got
corrupted by the Silicon Valley in the
sense of forget about this teaching
thing let's start companies instead so
now right now be enjoying the
intrapreneurship think that's great
that's great and of course I mean
there's been an eventful year for you
clearly urban public conversations yes
a major step a major milestone you built
and of course you guys doing the same
thing soon I'm not saying what came
before as if I'm a founders but you're
not the CEO obviously but from the
founders perspective yeah it's going
public is this this is like a great step
forward or insects carrion tanned and
and turning people walk risk-averse no
it's a great step forward if you have a
good team in place it's a good step
forward so the analogy really like after
actually going through the IPO and doing
it the energy was very similar to
graduating from Stanford
so a graduation graduation in general so
when he graduates
you're both scared because now you're
gonna be entering the real world but
you're also happy that you finished that
milestone and that's the exact same
feeling I had when we did the IPO so on
the IPO floor and after the IPO were
also happy that we finally achieved this
milestone at the same time we were kind
of a little bit worried and scared about
the future now that was a lots of
companies now avoid IPO and going too
late happy oh yeah B&B to uber is a good
example of companies that we billions
tens of Greene's rows of market cap yeah
and still don't go up here would you
advise him to go IPO I would I mean so
far and so again we have only been IPO
for a few months so my limit with our
limited IPO exposure absolutely like
frankly I don't see any difference
between being private an IPO from the
and from in terms of the investor
restrictions and discipline that you
have to exercise I mean again look at
uber despite them being a private
company they still had to have a CEO
change right because the investors
eventually become much more involved
even if your sizes bigger Institute
private and they can make changes like
that happen so I don't think it matters
if your private or
by the way he said you should teach for
us as you might know we have we teach in
Egypt we do yes in the Middle East yeah
I make actually my priority has been to
really bring hi Eric good education
specifically to the Middle East because
it's so close to where I grew up and in
some sense I don't think there's enough
of it in places like Egypt yeah
the big difference versus when you teach
with us you do it once and you teach for
the next three or four years yes which
we have been doing I mean caldera has
been don't mess with you and maybe me
personally at some point I can get back
in to do it right now I'm very busy with
each other itself making sure the
company continues to grow but yeah my
long-term kind of prospects if when I'm
done with Cabrera who knows when that
will be is yeah I mean teaching is that
me in my in my role model well yeah most
invited to come teach with us in big
scale or small scale or the tiny scale
and by the time I actually always saw as
a great give back to to to people oh
absolutely this because I mean we
learned so many things he and ii value
that the rest of the world doesn't know
one is you know ya know we can change
careers and so on yeah
change careers and economies and
countries yeah
before I open up to student questions I
just want to get your perspective and
data science there's so much hype about
artificial intelligence now and deep
learning and you know musk is telling us
you're very been slaves it's like
chicken because of AI what you take what
says change the last 15 years since you
started doing bitter science first I
don't make me with the unmasked we can
get back to that to his can we add this
I don't agree disagree disagree with him
here's kind of nightmare scenario this
painting that's all like very far away
from even happening
right now we can get back to that but
really what changed over the last 15
years is the abundance of data right so
so all of this very nice machine
learning and deep learning algorithms
that we are and that you are teaching
today they're not new they actually
existed 40 50 60 years ago the first
neural network was built about 70 years
ago what what is different though is for
these algorithms to work and to work
correctly they need data and you need
lots of data right and that's the
difference between the machines and the
humans is we are able to learn with
Allah
with a lot less data compared to
machines machines and all these
techniques that possibly possibly I mean
they spend years babbling and until we
then he can pass the nugget to a new kid
in school and teach them how to do
algebra and calculus like that right to
teach a a new network how to do calculus
he would lead a lot examples come again
feeding into that before it can actually
do it and that's kind of the one of the
key differences between our intellect
and the Machine intellect admire in my
opinion is that our ability to digest
and extract and repeat the key learnings
with a very small subset of input data
but that's the big change for machine
learning and why machine learning of
their science is making a comeback very
strong comeback is data availability of
data and availability of data comes from
a three key trends that took place the
first one is the IT movement the
information technology movement because
of a lot of us as organizations and
companies and countries moving a lot of
our processes to be happening in
computers we are enabled now to
instrument them and collect data about
them so that's number one and number two
is the mobile revolution that allowed us
to deploy and measure everywhere and
number three is the sensor network
revolution that allowed us to measure
everything not just about humans but
ever about cars about trains about
airplanes so so these three trends are
what led to the explosion of amount of
data available to us which was the
precursor to data science actually
working he asked a gutsy question since
you've been with the field for so long
and seen it evolve and of course our
what in the intellectual leaders the
forming of Coderre and and so on 15
years for now what should we be teaching
at Udacity what's going to happen in the
society when it comes to data so that's
15 years is a very long time in the rest
of the world how much happened in the
last 15 years
Facebook Amazon uber or always think how
there are you decid t all of these
things happen within the last 15 years
but I would say if if the trajectory
were on continues to evolve at the speed
it's at then the most important skill to
learn in the future will be the skill to
learn
that is the skill that we need to master
meaning having the flexibility and
adaptability to learn and acquire new
skills and that's why that's T is very
very important actually because that's
your mission is to make it easy for
people to learn new skills even when
they're 90 years old and that would be
the most important thing to take a
grander look at this whole journey I
frequent describe the wave that we're in
right now as the sixth wave of
automation six favor okay right that's a
sixth wave of automation and there is
five automation waves that happened
before to appreciate how lucky we are to
be living where we are today the first
wave happens a hundred thousand years
ago a hundred thousand years ago we
figured out this meaning speech mm-hmm
right and and when we figured out speech
humans figured out how to automate the
passing of knowledge from generation to
generation way quicker than any other
species and that's what made human Homo
sapiens really just go like this when
gorillas and and elephants and dolphins
stayed down here because we were able
now to pass information much quicker
using our speech versus depending on DNA
for passing knowledge so that was that
wave number one wave number two was ten
thousand years ago so there was ninety
thousand years between the first wave
from the second wave and the second wave
was when we figured out the automation
of making food so before that we had the
hunter-gatherers as you know and we had
to spend 16 hours per day just looking
for food we had no time to think no time
to learn no time to innovate we just
looked into the food most animals do
today yeah yeah exactly which is what
most animals do today exactly so when we
figured out agriculture when we had
these smart farmers who figured out
using the ebbs and flows of rivers and
Egypt actually play the big role in that
so I'm proud of Egypt's contributions
when it comes to that wave we and we
check it out planting seeds using cattle
we can grow food at much higher rates we
now feed ourselves to think a lot more
and actually another part that happened
there is we figured out cooking without
fire and we can cook food and cooking
food allowed our brain to absorb a lot
more energy which allowed us to evolve
much quicker as a species and another
very important thing that happened is we
now had enough food to feed our children
so our population we need started to
explode
that was the second wave sorry for going
into too much detail fast
it is it is the the third wave is the
wave of discovery automation of
discovery which is mathematics and
science the principles of math and
science and the scientific method and
chemistry biology and so on and that
happened around 3,000 years ago give or
take of course it doesn't happen like
overnight so that was the third wave the
fourth wave is getting much closer to
our time now and the fourth wave is the
Industrial Revolution which happened
around 200 years ago
300 years ago and that's when we figured
out how to use machines to build stuff
and move stuff as opposed to use our
arms right we depend on our arms to make
cloth and move things between towns and
build buildings and now we have machines
that help us do that at much higher
rates and so many people lost jobs
because of that but nobody would argue
that the end of evolution was so good
for all of us
in the long term and then wave number
five we lived with number five is the IT
movements and the IT movement is the
automation of processes just the process
how do we take a process of opening a
bank account or sending a letter and
doing that with whatsapp and snapchat
instead really that's what it's about
it's very important but at the end of
the day it's taking an existing process
and repeating that process in a much
quicker way the sixth wave the wave that
win right now there's a science wave I
refer to it as the automation of
decisions and hence will come out my
answer to your question the automation
of decisions is about how can we take
all of this data that's coming to us
from better sensors and mobile networks
and and better machines and then analyze
that data so we can take and automate
some of the decisions that the humans
make this is really what is it is about
so we can analyze how we drive a car and
automate the driving of cars which I
understand is one of the problems you
guys offer is the I've seen a day or two
and this yes I think our and then
another example from our customers is JP
Morgan and JP Morgan was able to take
decades of legal documents that their
lawyers had review for partnerships
they're doing with different partners
and now using machine learning they were
able to replace 400,000 lawyer hours
with ten minutes of computer time making
decisions about the
can language in these documents you're
not scared that they could take all the
brain walk away and you're unemployed
afterwards but exactly what if the ago
and company builds the digital CTO
they're much better they did thousand
out of your time is like twenty seconds
of their computer yes it's very possible
and that's why as I my answer to
question was what we need to do humans
what we need to do is to evolve
ourselves to be able to learn new skills
at much higher rates than ever before
because there will be no comfort zone
there will be no zone of I'm really good
at that I'm only gonna be a CTO for the
rest of my life now at some point that
will be replaced and you need to be good
at something else
so that's why the most important skill
of the future is what audacity is
working on which is teaching people how
to learn continuously all the time
thanks I mean I couldn't agree more with
everything you said I need to ask the
gutsy question first wave number seven
so wave one number seven it's very hard
to predict what exactly it would be but
my prediction from my knowledge would be
the augmentation of humans with
technology
it's it has been this integration of
computer and human thinking and not just
for the thinking for everything right so
you can look at the glasses I'm wearing
I used to wear glasses when I was young
but I did the laser surgery glasses were
the first kind of augmentation of
technology coming in to us and making us
better somebody who cannot see put the
thing on and they can see now we will
have things like that will help us
without health that will help us with
our thinking that will help us with our
hearing with our they were speaking with
everything around us and that would be
the second wave it's amazing now
actually this is already ongoing
I mean I have a little device here and
using this I can talk to a person
Australia which before I couldn't yeah
did I have a car or I can fly a plane
yeah oh yeah right I think I actually
envision that there can be a seamless
integration in our brains where we have
a chip in our brain just massive data
throughput to a computer center so the
moment we are born we can speak every
language differently like this yeah I
can't wait for that to happen thank you
I need to go to a student question I
want to ask you one question before do
this specifically because I mean we both
grew up in countries far away but
culturally I can country's even further
away it's very Islamic it's part the
Middle East it's at times in deep
trouble is economically not one of the
most rosy countries and hasn't been in
your childhood when when you talk to
young people from the Middle East today
in Egypt what do you recommend to him
and if they ask you how can I follow in
your footsteps and become a great
enterpreneur in Silicon Valley what
would you tell them so how to become an
entrepreneur not just in silicon I mean
not just a would be relevant somebody
from Egypt I think this would be having
somebody from any place in the world
it's a very hard question to answer
there's so many things that go into
making an intrapreneur become an
entrepreneur but I would say that one of
the very key elements that many would
agree on that entrepreneurs exhibit is
the willingness to take risk the
willingness to try things in new ways
and fail while trying these things but
learn from the failure very quickly and
adapt right and that's why immigrants
like myself and yourself attempt to have
a higher ratio of being entrepreneurs a
very recent study showed that 51 percent
of the current Silicon Valley unicorns
many companies across the billion in
valuation had at least one founder that
are that is an immigrant yeah I hope you
one percent like Sergey Brin yourself
yeah yeah so many so many examples of
that and and the reason why is I think
is that more than anything is as an
interpreter like an immigrant was
willing to take the biggest risk of all
which is leaving everything behind
leaving their country their friends
their family and starting a new
somewhere else so they have this natural
willingness to just try new things and
that makes them a very good fit to be
something you can teach something it's
as innate I think I think it's in it I
think it isn't it I think risk-taking is
very very innate and it's one of the key
things that I think investors look for
is is are you pretending to be a
risk-taker or are you truly a risk-taker
oh it's a dancer because I wish we could
teach it because I'm gonna agree with
you risk is the sauce and thick I would
argue the willingness to learn
it's already a risk-taking position
because learning means you do something
you don't know you know that it yeah and
you're willing to fail in that you have
learned something interesting so I think
it's innate but I think it's sometimes a
Nathan hidden and it needs to be
uncovered like in my case it was innate
and I could be just now being - -
arrogance but my case it was innate and
it was but it was hidden I wasn't when I
was young I was not thinking about being
an entrepreneur whatsoever what what
kept you from not thinking this way
bottom is the environment that the
environment is rate is very rare that
you would see a company a startup all
these things were very remote not
possible like somebody who saw the
company from fresh and there's not
something we didn't even think about and
when I came here and in the u.s.
especially to the Bay Area when I landed
in the airport just I passed my Oracle I
passed my Intel I passed by HP and the
first garage were HP actually started I
could go visit the garage and see this
is where it was fun and and that
triggers into you the the notion that
this is doable that people were doing
these things and and hence it cannot
switch me and in that way but I think I
mean there's many human skills or
talents that you cannot teach like say
I'm not a good singer are you a good
singer
can you sing my shower thinks I'm a good
singer so do you think we can teach you
to be a good singer it's very hard I
think singing can be taught honestly not
at the same level everybody yeah I think
it can be taught mmm I took singing
lessons when I was younger so any more
question is amazing but I want to ask
give some voice to our students because
it's a habit now or Udacity talks that
our students ask questions they have
much better question than we often some
are industry focused so Omar mmm sounds
they're gonna release a name yeah
ask hobby machine learning in artificial
intelligence shape data analysis yeah so
kind of answered a little bit would with
the sixth wave
talk that I gave but if you look at the
teller SS historically like data
analysis during the I T wave was very
focused on generating a report so we do
the analysis and we generate a report
and then that report a human like myself
or you would look at and make a decision
all right so we look at the numbers and
say oh that our our
student engagement is dropping we must
have done something wrong let's go back
and see what do we do and what led to
the student engagement dropping so the
analysis was very passive in that way
meaning the nurse's was simply about
generating something and then the human
had to take the action and the big shift
right now with their science and machine
learning what is introducing isn't using
this next mile of know that data will
not feed into a report that data will
fit into a decision that will be taken
yeah
the data will fit into a legal document
that will be generated automatically
will fit into a car that would be self
driven will will lead into a diagnostic
system that will tell you exactly what
disease you have and what medicine to
take without the doctor needing to be
involved at all and that's the big shift
interesting interesting it's it I mean
obviously I'm an optimist just like you
but it does have this little kind of
strange issue like what the machine
makes a bad decision and I don't get my
cancer removed yes I hear that criticism
all the time but so do everything humans
make bad decisions all the time machines
will make bad decisions but here's the
beauty of machines once they make the
bad decision and we correct for it they
will never make that bad decision again
ever and that's the difference that says
wait chant ask a question is it possible
for big data analytics to advance
substantially without further
compromising user privacy oh yes there's
no camera here so I think it's always
about the Bennets right it's always
about the balance and the exchange of
value you're giving up your privacy in
exchange for something and if you don't
get that something back then don't give
up your privacy so when I go to use for
example audacity and let's assume
audacity is monitoring how I'm taking
the class which is my privacy how
quickly I'm learning which is my privacy
how quickly and correctly I'm answering
or not answering questions which is my
privacy but then it's using that data to
change the flow of the course to give me
harder or easier content to make it
quicker for me to absorb the material
then I would take that there is a good
exchange of value I'm giving away my
privacy which is all the data about how
I'm interacting with material but in
exchange you're giving me value which
changing the flow of the material so I
can learn quick
and better and as long as we maintain
that formula of the exchange of the
privacy in exchange for value back to
you then it makes perfect sense if we
ever violate the trust that's when
things become bad and that's where the
government's need to step in and have
the laws and regulations that prevent
companies from abusing data in a way
that doesn't create a balance between
the privacy being giving up and the
value coming back so one dead end you
probably agree that something like then
NSA collecting data is not a bad thing
it's if they were to abuse it against us
that's the bad thing so that one is
controversial and the reason why that
one is controversial is I'm not getting
the value immediately so when they're
collecting data about me
it's not about giving me value it's
about trying to detect if somebody's
doing something bad and stopping them
from doing the bad thing that they were
going to do and that's where you need to
have the balance of okay I'm gonna add
that makes sense I want you to install
the bad guy from doing that but I have
to balance how much value how much data
you're taking away from me that you
should not and that's kind of where it
becomes very tricky to define an arrest
is a tricky question yeah yeah Roger ask
a question what tools and statistical
skills should a student have to become a
dear scientists a very good question I
would say take your courses here then an
degrees that you offer in the science
and machine learning and the
self-driving cars and so on but what's
really a good design I do a good data
scientists sit at the intersection of
three disciplines
the first one is business acumen meaning
and that's not something it learn in
school that's something you learn by
doing which is the ability to link
technical concepts and algorithms with
business concepts on it and and and
motivations and goals number two and
maybe we can create some you can create
some material around that but it's very
hard teach that usually you want to
experience that the second the
discipline is the discipline of
statistics and algorithms behind machine
learning and so on that's the science
behind machine learning and then the
third discipline is programming and the
programming language of the future for
the science as far as I'm concerned is
Python so having a very very good solid
grasp of Python is essential to succeed
as an IDE teach here it's interesting
interesting how fast this shifts because
short time ago would have said MATLAB
yeah are ya know I'm Atlas I read that
is long run and continues
be one of the best scientific places
languages to use for scientific
discovery and simulations and so on now
if you look at this science through you
at the beginning of those science it
it it started with our and SAS and now
there is a very very big shift towards
Python yeah very very and I love Python
to be honest most stuff I ask a question
is more career-focused
Silicon Valley is seen as an innovation
hub source of course your company what
you've contributed
how can a gypped
how can a when similar other
countries in the Middle East replicate
or even advance beyond this kind of sort
of innovative startup culture yeah so we
discuss that briefly in previous
questions it's not just the Egypt thing
the entire world
I mean Europe and Asia and and and and
South America has managed to get ahead I
mean four of the ten largest tech
companies are Chinese yes so China is
definitely very very impressive not
India and all in the done in Africa
there's some examples but you're right
China definitely is very impressive when
it comes to that and I think it goes
back to the risk-taking behavior that
they're willing to take risks but the
reason Silicon Valley became Silicon
Valley is the the combination of three
things in my opinion the first one is
entrepreneurs people willing to take
risk people willing to leave a very big
job with a very big salary at Microsoft
or IBM and say I'm gonna start the
company so that was number one and I
will back then when HP started I don't
know what the GE or one of the big
companies back then so that's number one
is willing to leave a big comfortable
salary to start something new which is
the risk-taking thing maybe so that's
number one
nobody HP by the way founders gave up
tenure at Stanford Wow which is even
like that's a huge risk because once you
give that up it's very hard to get it
back it's just getting tenure is very
hard number two is risk but risk on the
other side on the money side so having
investors willing to put money behind a
start-up which is very hard most
investors like I think it's one of the
biggest problems any time in the least
is most also them still think like
Investment Banking
but VC is very different from Investment
Banking VC for every investment you
gonna for every 10 investment
gonna make you'll be lucky if one of
them did very well and and sometimes
even it's now 100,000 will do very very
well and become a public company with a
very high valuation and that's something
very hard for them to get their minds
around use more to businesses which are
a spreadsheet you have the spreadsheet
you can see that growth you can see how
much they're spending on their employees
and this is how much more we can invest
in them to make this much more money but
much more deterministic much more lower
returns obviously and because of that
but that's the second thing and then the
third the third important thing is the
availability of talents so one of the
benefits here of the Bay Area is they
have two very major hubs Stanford
University and the battery sister the
the the UC system producing tons and
tons of talent feeding into the system
and that all of these things existed at
the beginning seventy years ago when HP
was one of the very first artists was
born so that's what's needed to
replicate and the harder of these three
is the first two Alex asks the question
what would you tell yourself as your
your 20 year old self now what would I
tell my 20 years oh my 20 year old so if
that was the person that just came to
the u.s. back in 1995 I would have told
them to buy a lot of Apple stock 1995
Apple existed and Apple was a penny
stock I guess which penny stock would
you buy today I think I love the idea of
having a profit in your family
Alex accident may be the same of maybe
different Alex asking a question I'm
gonna excite you change it but yes the
question what fears and tech do you
believe are going to grow fast in the
next 10 years but even today what do you
think are the fast growing things that
are coming at us right now yeah so I
mean first I'm very biased so I think
our fields meaning the machine learning
they're science field this is definitely
going to be a few things as I have seen
no content yeah so that the
again thank you for affirming Deb
another field which I think will evolve
very quickly is what we referred to
earlier which is the augmentation
virtual reality augmented reality
devices that go on our body and help us
do things at with much higher efficiency
than we can with our normal body today I
think that that's gonna be a competition
it's such a wide field I mean my
airplane augments my ability to move
around my cell phone augments my ability
to talk to somebody else or access maybe
I don't know stock take us some things
we wouldn't like you mentioned the
languages thing so if I if I have a
device I can put in my ear or even my
brain that are on that helps me
understand any language so I travel a
lot across the world right now and it's
a big trench when you travel to a
country where you have no idea what
people are saying so you need Google
glass plus plus plus plus with something
in my ear as well so know who does a
good ear device as well that can do
real-time translation and also a
real-time text mapping when I look at a
sign like this you know that Google
Translate does on the phone but you say
it what I'm getting in here yeah makes
perfect sense
yeah what else like what cool stuff
should be working order of the people
working on anybody curious because I'm a
CTO a technology officer
yeah I'm just the president I mean we
continue to I mean there's no question
about the cloud wave being a very
significant wave we're still at the
beginning of it despite all the success
that AWS and amazon has we're still at
the beginning of the cloud way most
large enterprises in the world right now
all of their processing is happening
inside of their own their centers you
know and we only are experiencing the
beginning of that yeah so that is
another big wave that's gonna maybe I
have a theory why this is moving slower
than it should be because most big
corporation have like 1,000 or 5,000 IT
professionals yeah and when the
questions ask the question should go to
the cloud they get together and realize
oh my god I'm gonna lose my job
they say yes so you're gonna find every
reason in order to say no yeah so we
need your help there we need you we need
you to have more and more courses that
can help these people be adaptive as I
said that the most important skill in
the future is to be adaptive in your
skills thank you
are you planning any more education with
Udacity as a company yes I would love to
do that yes I can tell you I mean you
were perhaps our earliest or one of the
two or three earliest partners
and it was such an eye-opening thing to
to be able to get something done by a
company as opposed to academia and I'm
recovering academic I'm a bit like the
the role that you wanted to go to give
up tenure yeah but getting getting a
company Coderre to tell us what really
is hot right now was so much more
interesting than having any kind of
number of professors talk to over that
kind of thoughts know what's going on so
yeah I think both are important but the
balance is very important yeah well I
think we almost the out of town is
anything you want to add to our students
in the world so I think I like one key
piece of advice I would give and I think
this applies to anything not just being
entrepreneur its perseverance is it have
a sense of perseverance whatever you're
working on whatever you're dedicated to
just don't give up easy do you think
perseverance can be taught it can be
nurtured give me no jealousy so if you
have not been meaning it can be taught
from the bit from early on if you have
not been taught from early on to have a
sense of perseverance it's very hard to
get it back into you yeah that's the
case yeah it's really fascinating
talking to you and again boy I could say
from all the eleven you just talks is
probably one agreed with them all your
six stages of society are fun super
enlightening I guess you left out the
agricultural you should be probably
fallen to Industrial Revolution no no I
did mention okay the second wave second
wave is agriculture nobody more recent
one the agricultural evolution happen
with steam engine and oh ok farming but
I guess it's a very similar to industry
yeah thanks so much for coming it's
fascinating I would love to spend many
more hours video and thanks for being
such a great partner to our students in
the world I have to admit I find it
inspiring especially meeting someone
who's made it for the world
the way you amaura have and and has
stayed humble and open-minded there's so
much for us to learn for all of us to be
honest in what can be done and I mean
you know we have Udacity as one piece of
total contribution to help everyone to
learn new skills I'd love to learn
or teach skills that I go way beyond it
the things that you call innate that I
actually believe can be taught like
we're taking maybe or singing class but
yeah I mean I think I think if anything
of each about Aaron each of many years
ago and I loved the energy of the
country love the innovation and
freshness that I could see at the same
time you're right the infrastructure to
turn this energy into something massive
and even oral is missing and I think
they'll be missing unfortunate for quite
a while for these countries yeah but boy
I'm inspired I'm inspired meeting you
thank you for coming
absolutely my pleasure
you